Bob Cusack joins us he is
editor-in-chief of the hill Bob good
morning morning so it's not unusual for
the president to double down not back
away from rhetoric we are seeing that
pattern play out once more help us
understand the political benefit here
for the president and continuing with
this back and forth with representative
Omar in particular well this certainly
plays to his base but at the same time
base voters can't vote twice he's got
the base and some Republicans wish as
certainly next year he's gonna have to
broaden his base and appeal to
independents who picked him over Hillary
Clinton so politically yeah it works but
he's already got this part of the voting
block already how does this play with
those swing voters I felt like this I
think it hurts him I think it's a big
controversy I think people are tired of
the controversies and that's why I think
it's gonna be difficult for him to win
those voters over again yeah it all
depends of course who the Democratic
nominee is though well the house
condemned his his remarks as racist but
it fell upon party lines pretty much
what what our Republican lawmakers doing
to distance themselves or are they well
they are just very carefully because if
you distance yourself too much from the
president then you could lose a primary
and that's what they're very concerned
about and we've seen people like Mark
Sanford Republican from South Carolina
lost his primary because he distanced
himself too much is there a new
definition for racism and racist I mean
I think that's the the crux of what is
happening here yeah and you're gonna see
race throughout this and if you thought
the 2016 election was ugly this is gonna
be uglier because race is gonna dominate
the 2020 race that was gonna be my
question is how do you think what we're
seeing play out right now where it
appeared the president was sort of
floating this notion with the tweet
first of all initially where he sort of
stepped into this debate that was
happening within the Democratic Party
right you heard these more Congress
women very much on the Left going at it
in a public way with House Speaker Nancy
Pelosi president Trump inserting himself
with these tweets last weekend and then
now escalating the point where you have
these send her back chants what does
this mean for 2020 as he hits the
campaign trail well this means that when
Democrats are fighting that Trump is
going to always insert himself and I
think in this situation it was
remarkable Nancy Pelosi and Andy's
for freshmen were fighting publicly you
didn't see that before and and this is I
think backfired on president Bob Muller
testifies this week the delayed
testimony there was no state police last
week now this week what are both parties
looking to get out of this testimony
well certainly Democrats need some new
news and I think they have to have some
distance between Muller and attorney
general Barr that's what I think they
are they're gonna focus on
however Muller I think it's going to
dodge a lot of questions Republicans are
gonna say case closed it's over why are
we doing this and there is some Muller
fatigue in this country no doubt about
it does this force the issue even
Pietschmann for a Democrat that's a big
question does it move the needle and if
it doesn't well then Democrats at some
point I think this you're gonna have to
decide impeachment or not they can't go
into 2020 with this question still open
Bob Cusack thank you very much thank you